but in the past couple of hours there's
already been a lot of movement within
the cabinet one of the key developments
Jacob Ray smog resigning as business
secretary he was a close Ally of Liz
truss and Boris Johnson's and had
earlier said that he wasn't expecting to
serve in Rishi sunax cabinet
well let's bring you a quick Round Up of
who else has left their position within
government this afternoon
the Justice secretary Brandon Lewis he
resigned saying it was an honor to have
been one of the longest serving cabinet
ministers having done eight ministerial
roles in five departments under four
Prime Ministers he added that the new
prime minister would have his support
from the back benches
the chief whip Wendy Morton resigned
posting a short statement on Twitter it
read heading to the back benches from
where I will continue to represent the
constituencies constituents businesses
and communities of Aldridge Brown Hills
the work and pension secretary Chloe
Smith is also out today she posted a
statement that said it has been a
privilege to serve as the Secretary of
State for work and pensions and I would
like to thank all of the brilliant staff
at the department for work and pensions
she added I look forward to supporting
Rishi sudak from the back benches and
continuing to work hard for my
constituents in Norwich North
uh next up Vicki Ford the minister of
State for development in the foreign
Commonwealth and development office she
posted a statement on Twitter saying
there is no greater honor than
representing the UK overseas she added
that she wished her success over she
seen that all the very best
sorry that should be Liz truss's
successor uh also gone is the Secretary
of State for Wales Robert Buckland who
said it's been an honor to serve as
Secretary of State for Wales and to have
served four Prime Ministers as solicitor
general Justice Minister Andrew
Chancellor he added I am leaving the
government at my request but will be
supporting Rishi sunak from the back
benches
Jake Ferry the conservative party
chairman has gone as well he said it's
been an honor to serve as the
conservative party chairman but all good
things must come to an end adding I
relish the opportunity to serve our
great party and my constituents from the
back benches once again
also our kit motels the education
secretary and the minister of State for
the environment ranel Jaya Warden he has
also gone saying that the new prime
minister wished to have a new team in
government and so he would stand aside
the leveling up secretary Simon Clark he
said it's been a great privilege to
serve as Secretary of State for leveling
up working alongside some terrific
people to level up our communities
well a growing list of who is out yet to
find out who is in we're watching and
waiting our political correspondent Liz
Bates is here with me now any big
surprises as to who's left so far well I
think when we look at who's left so far
it's mostly people that are big Liz
trust supporters so I think that is
quite unsurprising at this stage it does
seem like it's going to potentially uh
all happen
um quite quickly I think it's you know
we sort of see like outside at number 10
this morning saying that he's prepared
to make tough decisions but also that he
wants to unify the party so this is the
first big test of those two things and I
think it'll be interesting to see first
of all
um I mean you look at people like Jacob
Reese Mark he's been very critical of
Richard sunac in the past so maybe it
wasn't really possible for him to stay
in cabinet but you also look at someone
like you know Therese coffee she's
Health secretary Deputy Prime Minister
brought in under Liz trust as one of her
um which was serving already but you
know one of Liz truss's best mates
really what again what is going to
happen to people like that you know you
look at the figures in the cabinet as
well and the deems of Harley James
cleverley they just backed Boris Johnson
in the leadership contest that happened
over the last couple of days will they
be punished for that or is he really
going to keep people like that within
the fold so it'd be interesting to see
that other questions like what's he
going to do with Penny Morden she just
ran against him what she clearly proved
in doing that is that she has a lot of
support within the party will he reward
her with a big job or will he keep her
in the job that she's in at the moment
leader of the House of Commons I'm sure
she'll be hoping that he will promote
her so all of these questions you know
another thing
um you know the leadership contest that
happened over the summer the uh the the
characters in that Sue Ella Braverman
kemi badenark
um Tom tugenhart will they be brought
into cabinet or will he decide you know
what we've just run against each other
maybe it's not a good time to have those
people around me and one more thing his
loyalists the people that he's been
friends with and political allies with
for a long time but also people like
Dominic Rob who has really put his neck
on the line for Rishi sunak back to him
will he be rewarded with one of those
big jobs Home Secretary foreign
secretary so all of these questions the
richest United will be thinking about
but it you know it seems like he's going
to make decisions very quickly so it
might be that we get answers to all of
these questions very soon